okay [ __ ] okay [ __ ] we're playing
this scary [ __ ] game when I said
scared I say [ __ ] is terrifying oh
that's secret ok and now this game is
I'm playing a detective so detective
psychobabble oh I can i watch em I 20th
Bullard was found dead in his study five
days ago no nobody believes me but I
think he was murdered this house in the
middle of nowhere holds the secret
there's a story hiding here and I'm
going to cover it okay good if I'm right
there are four major suspect hot chick
grand Wellington Josie Herrera as hang
Cynthia Pakman life Bobby Sawyer errand
boy I'm not leaving until I find out
what happened okay let's say this [ __ ]
is that like tapping noise
wait my serious bro there's no walking
him oh [ __ ] you have to click on things
hold on hold on yeah there ain't no
walking in this game ah [ __ ] it I ok
address2 era sent from downtown guv now
just need answer evidencing it out of
here professor and an home monk and zest
at college it over by bobbys so worked
at errand boy okay okay ballin moves
into know what I'm close well it's
higher state hey I'm not Astra Adric
Luke I'm dead-ass study plea ethnic and
errands for him on the body lemon
assistant I had a life inheritor a leg
all the research that's operative
absolute
well let's go in the crime scene awk
that the [ __ ] oh yeah
keifa first I don't like how this game
actually there we go thank you thank s
they get the crime say look let's go
[ __ ] ah yes yes oh now
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] here its remaining
script okay the man you could say with
this again
see with ask an idea folk Oh
[Music]
oh it's a good branding sense a big deal
and here Mets a record of the side
pana are you like I a great night
outside noise hot set that's bird
pecking right here a snowwoman an old
man is some climbing around to collect
firewood
a sudden Antonia and how late [ __ ]
word on a second head
[Music]
holy [ __ ] okay so they met a creepy
woman they said don't tell anyone or
I'll kill you here's lady's life trying
to life it was snow woman and AH shat I
like this
I [ __ ] is that why statue is a mess
saying LM
and note the earth
where's that
that's I care
I say yeah how does a better cut out
vonces [ __ ] fun okay
eres bullet I am the woodcutter your
pass has gone up at the odds over a
[ __ ] I'm here err silicon air the way
that yes camera lens ya ass up around
the house Bob up idea focal lenses I
kids
it's them
oh it's less
ah
a very scary and X
[ __ ] me I can japanese not there
I'm classic
I'm sure and I see the kingdom
with it say
akagi
Lt
ok welcome over academia
bah 10
Oh
[Music]
you
you
sharam [ __ ] burn
oh great ask right
[Music]
it was [ __ ] bus not yet
acquittal no wait
hooked it Oh is there a piece missing
somewhere
that's their hang
Earth's okay back to it active
and I which buttons now
last ace
class taste earth
wait that's what North like so it's
backwards
there we go ah [ __ ]
I hate this
because if you're reading this note then
something must have happened I may I may
be dead or missing he the only one I
could save their research with his being
thorough answered before I left college
I get utter accessor
of a [ __ ] watch all these here with them
ask of them I've locked their research
away in the safe room student sure
everything I'll burn the house down if
yet if the research to get out of here
if the
josie's a good person
[ __ ] getting scary that's for sure
what cutter
[ __ ] huh any fur jumps okay luck is that
here we go I'm gonna get attacked it's
unnerving that's all right I can left
that's behind me nothing or use the
goggles
yeah that's ariza's helicopter may win
I'm wool and something i wonder far I'll
said Huck I'll it back what is this I'd
ship all right he's an anniversary five
years ago that i found out tonight old
research you're in it we eat you at
Aranda oh mama africa ack i right hello
Flo
Oct sure here goes nothing
boggles it's jen I all-mountain [ __ ] s
it might say a reporter on my desk but I
spend most of my time at the standard
making coffee for my editor I'm tired of
writing the gossip column this story is
my shot at the big leagues when I prove
that Bullard was murdered all the big
papers will come calling I'll finally
escape this backwater town this is it
the chance I've been waiting for a good
girl you go
yes sir my agent you and something Bobby
after I'll typed up it's okay pop is
Sawyer
I finally got dad on the porch ink all
over him everybody was up acted other
app on his salt into the man's phone
they found a map third kind of way to
the cave a Bobby
and watching you we had to go to the
other room I don't know [ __ ] that's it
all right okay ah shut I don't weird
[ __ ] got on here
ok Eric every other smells care
f
oh I forgot right here and I guess up
with this right here and I'll I step
and
rien and scissor parts
or that is [ __ ] up
[Music]
okay what oh my god that's from the item
phone call instead of unfiltered I'll
choose from
this box says right that's what it
yes
office on
and
bill told me to cover Bullards death but
he's just looking for gossip about
assisted but I took it seriously did the
research followed every lead like a real
journalist would it paid off I found
something everybody else missed a note
half thought scribbled in the margins of
the coroner's draft report it read
hypothermia in summer
ah um